eric drouet a été relaxé c'est la fin de
son parcours judiciaire qui s'achève sur
une victoire
il avait été interpellé le 22 février
2020 au salon de l'agriculture alors
qu'ils tentaient de s'approcher du
président or les services de sécurité de
la présidence l'avait repéré et il avait
écarté palper les gardiens de la paix
partie civile durant l'audience ont
expliqué qu'ils règlent drouet avait
opposé une résistance en faisant des ges
en faisant le poids mort ce qui explique
son inculpation pour rébellion et
rigoureux et de son côté a expliqué ne
pas avoir compris qu'il s'agissait de
policiers puisqu'ils étaient en civil
qui n'avaient pas décliner leurs
fonctions mais qui ne s'étaient pas
montrés violents ce qui a été attestée
par plusieurs vidéos diffusées durant
l'audience
et finalement le président a statué que
faire des jets sont encore le poids mort
n'était pas constitutifs du délit de
rébellion
on écoute eric drouet et son avocat caps
lara bas quand ça se finit comme ça je
suis content d'ailleurs heureusement que
la loi sur le sur les policiers n'est
pas encore passé parce que sans vidéo
tout aurait pu être dit et le jugement
se serait pas passé pareil de toute
façon je suis content que comme la
justice viennent sanctionner à quelque
chose qui est inadmissible
je dis toujours que pour eric drew et
c'est tout à fait symptomatique comment
les jets les jeux ne sont traitées les
plus de soucis judiciaires c'était la
dernière affaire je suis assez heureux
mais quand même on s'est quand même
beaucoup battu sur nombreuses procédures
et en résultat il a eu des relaxes
partout c'est la troisième relaxe pour
eric drew et dans le cadre de son
implication dans le mouvement des gilet
jaune
son avocat cab sera blâmé le fait
qu'avec lui c'était toujours la même
chose des interpellations en série
il ne fallait pas qu'il soit sur le
chemin du président de la république
pour vos idées politiques on vous met en
garde à vue a déploré l'avocat lors de
sa plaidoirie